13 beautiful losers
have you ever noticed that addicts are
often extremely interesting people
addiction itself is excruciatingly
boring
it's boring because it's predictable the
lies the evasions the transparent
self-justifications and
self-exonerations
but the addict himself is often a
colorful and fascinating person
if he has been a substance abuser for
any length of time
his story often reads like a novel
packed with drama
conflict and intrigue if the addict's
drug of choice is alcohol
the narrative is frequently one of job
loss domestic abuse divorce
abandonment of children bankruptcy if
class 1 narcotics are the culprit
the tail often includes troubles with
the law crime
prison time violence even death
of course you and i can be addicted to a
number of things
to love to sex to worship of our own
children or our parents
to dominance to submission we can even
be addicted to ourselves
see charlie sheen donald trump
such individuals can be absolutely
fascinating at the same time that
they're boring as hell
what then is the connection between
addiction
and resistance
14 art and addiction
for the past several years i've written
a weekly post on my website
called writing wednesdays far and away
the most popular entries in that space
have been in my
artist and addict series one of the
points those posts made
was that there's not that big a
difference between an artist and an
addict
many artists are addicts and vice versa
many are artists in one breath
and addicts in another what's the
difference
the addict is the amateur the artist is
the professional
both addict and artist are dealing with
the same material
which is the pain of being human and the
struggle against self-sabotage
but the attic slash amateur and the
artist slash professional
deal with these elements in
fundamentally different ways
when i say addiction by the way i'm not
referring only to the serious clinical
maladies of alcoholism
drug dependence domestic abuse and so
forth
web surfing counts too so do compulsive
texting
sexting twittering and facebooking
distractions
displacement activities when we're
living as
amateurs we're running away from our
calling
meaning our work our destiny the
obligation to become our truest and
highest selves
addiction becomes a surrogate for our
calling
we enact the addiction instead of
embracing the calling
why because to follow a calling requires
work
it's hard it hurts it demands entering
the pain
zone of effort risk and exposure
so we take the amateur route instead
instead of composing our symphony
we create a shadow symphony of which we
ourselves are the orchestra the
conductor the composer
and the audience our life becomes a
shadow drama
a shadow startup company a shadow
philanthropic venture
have you ever been to new orleans in
tennessee williams
southern cities savannah and charleston
also come to mind you find
characters the colorful old lady with 39
cats
the purple-haired dude who has turned
his apartment into a shrine to james
dean
in the south you can get away with that
stuff it's kind of cool
the shadow enactment has been elevated
to such a level that it becomes
folklore even almost art
my life used to be a shadow novel it had
plot
characters sex scenes action scenes it
had mood
atmosphere texture it was scary it was
weird it was exciting
i had friends who were living out shadow
movies or creating
shadow art or initiating shadow
industries
these were our addictions and we worked
them for all they were worth
it was only one problem none of us was
writing a real novel
or painting a real painting or starting
a real business
we were amateurs living in the past or
dreaming of the future
while failing utterly to do the work
necessary to progress
in the present when you turn pro
your life gets very simple the zen monk
the artist the entrepreneur often lead
lives so plain they're practically
invisible
miyamoto musashi's dojo was smaller than
my living room
things became superfluous for him in the
end
he didn't even need a sword the amateur
is an egotist he takes the material of
his personal pain
and uses it to draw attention to himself
he creates a life
a character a personality the artist and
the professional on the other hand
have turned a corner in their minds they
have succeeded
in stepping back from themselves they
have grown so bored with themselves and
so sick of their petty [ __ ]
that they can manipulate those elements
the way a hazmat technician
handles weapons-grade plutonium they
manipulate them for the good of others
what were once their shadow symphonies
become real symphonies
the color and drama that were once
outside now move
inside turning pro is an act of
self-abnegation
not self with a capital s but little s
self
ego distraction displacement addiction
when we turn pro the energy that once
went into the shadow novel
goes into the real novel what we once
thought was
real the world including its epicenter
ourselves
turns out to be only a shadow and what
it seemed to be only a dream
becomes now the reality of our lives
15 resistance and addiction
the pre-addictive individual i.e you and
i when we're young
experiences a calling to art to service
to honorable sacrifice in other words we
experience
positive aspiration a vision of the
higher
realized self we might become
the intimation of this calling is
followed immediately
by the apparition of resistance fear
self-doubt self-sabotage what makes this
moment so so
precarious is that most of us are
unconscious in the event
of both our aspirations and our
resistance we're asleep
we know only that something is wrong and
we don't know how to fix it
we're restless we're bored we're angry
we burn to accomplish something great
but we don't know where to begin and
even if we did we'd still be so
terrified that we couldn't take a step
enter a drink a lover
a habit addiction replaces
aspiration the quick fix wins out over
the long
slow haul
16 addiction and shadow careers
when we can't stand the fear the shame
and the self-reproach that we feel
we obliterate it with an addiction the
addiction becomes the shadow version
the evil twin of our calling to service
or to art
that's why addicts are so interesting
and so boring at the same time
they're interesting because they're
called to something
something new something unique something
that we watching
can't wait to see them bring forth into
manifestation
at the same time they're boring because
they never do the work
instead the attic enacts his aspiration
in shadow form
the addiction becomes his novel his
adventure
his great love the work of art or
service that might have been produced
is replaced by the drama conflict and
suffering
of the addict's crazy haunted shattered
life
17 the addict as dramatic hero
robert mckee in his story seminars
testifies that the essential quality in
a fictional protagonist
i.e the hero in a book or a movie is
that he or she
must possess the passion and the will to
push the story to the limits of human
experience
in order to achieve their goal otherwise
there would be no story
this heroic monomania is also the
definition of the addict
the lush or the junkie will sell her own
mother to score the substance she is
jonesing for
18 why i don't knock addiction
addictions are not bad they are simply
the shadow forms of a more noble and
exalted calling
our addictions are our callings
themselves only encrypted
and incognito they are a metaphor for
our best selves
the coded version of our higher
aspirations
addictions and shadow careers are
messages in a bottle from our
unconscious
our self in the jungian sense is trying
to get our attention
to have an intervention with us the
question we need to ask of a shadow
career or an addiction
is the same question the psychotherapist
asks of a dream
what is our unconscious trying to tell
us